ja willkommen zu aktuellen digitalen
ersatzsitzungen über Kanz und leg uns
mit der sekretiten heute haben wir uns
zentrale Leitfragen überlegt die
bestimmt kann das Verhältnis von Wille
und von Vernunft und besteht Unterschied
zwischen kategorischen und
hypothetischen imperativen wie es nach
Kant ein kategorischer Imperativ möglich
das ist die zentrale Frage der
Grundlegung Somiten es gibt noch eine
Frage funktioniert nach Kant der
sogenannte maximentest das kategorischen
Imperativs es sind die vier Fragen die
wir uns heute anhand von zentralen
Textauszügen gemeinsam anschauen wollen
ja ich bringe ein paar zentrale Zitate
da habe ich richtige Teile für markiert
er sagt kann und das betrifft jetzt
erste Frage nach dem Verhältnis von
Vernunft und wähle nur ein vernünftiges
Wesen hat das Vermögen nach der
Vorstellung der Gesetze das heißt
Prinzipien zu handeln oder einen Willen
er will er sagte ist nichts anders als
praktische Vernunft
der Wille sagt einer anderen Stelle ist
ein Vermögen nur dasjenige zu wählen was
die Vernunft unabhängig von der Neigung
als praktischen notwendig das heißt als
gut erkennt jetzt kann man sich
natürlich fragen ist der Wille wirklich
immer ein Vermögen zu demjenigen was die
Vernunft als gut erkennt kann ich nicht
auch manchmal etwas wollen was die
Vernunft nicht als gut erkennt oder
in different erkennt das ist eine großes
Problem in ganz Philosophie jedenfalls
ist das die Grundlage der Wille wird in
der Regel als ein vernünftiger Wille
verstanden der nach der Vorstellung von
Gesetzen das heißt nach Prinzipien
handelt
jetzt erkannt der aber Gesetze mit
Vernunft zusammenhängen muss der Wille
vernünftig sein die kann man natürlich
wieder fragen was für eine Art
garantiert im Sinne es gibt ja zwei
Arten von 5 mindestens instrumentelle
Vernunft und moralische fünf
jetzt geht's aber um die Frage wie das
Verhältnis von kategorischen Imperativ
und hypothetischen Imperativ zu denken
ganz allgemeins erkannt dass die Formel
des Gebots Imperativ heißt
weil das sagt er dass der Mensch
ein Willen hat der nicht immer darum
etwas tut weil im vorgestellt wird das
ist gut sei das heißt die Moral muss für
den Menschen immer weil er eben nicht
immer schon der vernunftvoll geleistet
eine Sache der Nötigung sein also das
Zwangs
und zwar müsst muss dieser Zwang so
verständigen werden dass er mit Gründen
zu tun hat also mit vernünftigen Gründen
das hängt natürlich wieder mit ganz
Begriff der Pflicht zusammen auch mit
seinen Begriff der Art und die wir schon
diskutiert haben
jetzt unterscheiden kann ganz prominent
zwischen hypothetischen kategorischen
imperativen hypothetisch Sympathie also
jene die politischen die geben nur immer
relativ etwas als Mittel zum Zweck vor
in der Zweck ein andere ist dann müssen
auch die Mittel anders sein das heißt
andere Mittel werden geboten
es geht hier allerdings beim
kategorischen Imperativ darum ob etwas
als an sich gut ist und nicht nur als
Mittel sind wegfällt es wäre Instrument
Telefon es geht halt um moralische das
hängt natürlich wieder ganz eng mit ganz
Begriff des guten Willens zusammen gut
ist ja nur ein guter Weg
jetzt geht er genauer auf den
kategorischen Imperativ ein und hier ist
jetzt entscheiden der betrifft nicht die
Materie der Handlung als auch nicht den
konkreten Zweck
schon gar nicht die Folge ja das ja kein
utilitarrist kein konsequenzialist
sondern nur die Form das Prinzip woraus
sie die Handlung erfolgt
das ist nach Kant der Imperativ der
Sittlichkeit
wie kann man sich das jetzt genau
vorstellen
er sagte doch mal Unterschied zum
hypothetischen Imperativ ist das sieht
bloß von subjektiver Gültigkeit ist die
sollte jeder Mensch dies oder jenes zu
seiner Glücklichkeit zähle das hängt
davon ab hypothetischen relativ der
eignet sich nicht dazu eine absolute
jetzt fragte sich wir sind diese
imperative hypothetischen Kategorien
möglich
ganz einfach sagt Kant ist der
hypothetisch Imperativ zu erklären da
sagte der braucht keiner besonderen
Erörterung denn besitzernargument wird
den Zweck will will sofern die Vernunft
auf seine Handlung entscheiden hat auch
das dazu unehrlich notwendig ermittelt
das in seiner Gewalt ist es scheint
schon daraus zu folgen wenn ich einen
bestimmten Zweck will dann will ich auch
das Mittel zu seiner Realisierung und
das gibt mir wiederum die hypothetische
Imperativ an das ist also recht
trivialitätischen Partie schwieriger
wird es jetzt wie den partitiv der
Sittlichkeit wirklich sein das ist ganz
schwierig und kann sagt hier das wir
eigentlich gar nie wissen können ob wir
moralisch handeln
es kann nämlich sein dass wir insgeheim
aus er sagte dunklen Besorgnis
Moral scheinbar moralischer also in eine
ganz schwierige Sache diesen
kategorischen aktiv zu begründen auch zu
verstehen
ja als er sagt wir müssen also diesen
kategorischen Imperativ
hypothetisch nicht bestimmen sondern ihm
kategorisch und zwar
Apriori das heißt vor allem einfach wir
können ihn nicht aus der Erfahrung
ableiten das kann man nur mit
hypothetischen aktiv
sonst
hätten wir es nur mit Prinzipien des
Willens aber nicht mitgesetzt zu tun der
kategorisch Imperativ hat das mitgesetzt
zu tun unbedingt der Gültigkeit
jetzt sagte zum über den kategorischen
Imperativ dass die einzelnthetisch
praktischer Satz ist Apriori
was heißt das jetzt
da sind jetzt
drei wichtige Begriffe drin oder
zumindest zwei
ein praktischer satzansatz der sich auf
die Handlung bezieht der eigentlich ein
normativer Satz ist
und er ist normativ a priori also nicht
erst durch Erfahrung wenn ich jetzt
empirisch durch Erfahrung gelernt habe
dass ich immer dieses Mittel zu diesem
Zweck brauche das wäre
apostyriori der kategorische Imperativ
der muss durch eine vernünftige Belegung
und sind in der metaphysiken als gültig
erkannt werden können und jetzt ist er
auch noch ein synthetischer Satz also
kein Satz der wie jetzt der
hypothetische Imperativ sich allein aus
der Anlage her ergibt das natürlich ein
Mensch der einen bestimmtes Ziel
verfolgt dass der natürlich auch die
Mittel zu diesem Ziel will das wäre
analytisch aber ganz einfach bei dem
kategorischen Stativ geht es um etwas
was wir nicht durch lose Analyse
herausbekommen können also dass wir zum
Beispiel nicht lügen sondern es war
kategorisch nicht mein Fall eine Notlüge
das kann ist etwas was wir nicht durch
Begriffsanalyse ausbringen können wie
das Verhältnis von Zweck und bitte Gebot
was und das ist etwas was für uns
überraschend ist dass dieses Gebot gilt
deswegen nennt ihr das synthetisch ist
also nicht analytisch sondern
gehaltserweitert kein theoretischer
synthetischer Satz
wie etwa die Sätze der Mathematik
bekannt synthetische Sätze aprioris sind
ein synthetisch praktisches auf die
Frage bezieht wie wir handelt sind und
auch da sagt dann gibt es synthetische
apriorische Sätze die eben auch so
schwierig sind wie die
theoretischen synthetischen Sätze das
ist ja die Frage seiner theoretischen
Philosophie wir sind synthetische Sätze
abbrio wie möglich setzt der Physik
setzt der Mathematik die mit Raum und
Zeit in rein anschauungsform von
Raumzeit zu tun haben
ja
jetzt sagte hier folgendes
der hypothetische Imperativ der lässt
uns nicht gleich wissen was er einteilt
denn wir wissen es erst dann wenn wir
die Bedingungen haben also wenn wir das
Ziel ist dann ist wissen wir was der
hypothetischen Partie relativ sonst sind
Gebiete man kategorischen literativ ist
es anders denkt nicht von unseren Zielen
ab so vom Handeln und wollen genau
gesagt überhaupt
denke ich mir einen kategorischen Partie
so weiß ich sofort Wasser enthalte
er enthält natürlich kein Materiales
Gebot keine Bedingung die relativ ist
sondern nur die allgemeine Allgemeinheit
eines Gesetzes überhaupt also wir schon
mal sagte nur die reine Form des Wollens
überhaupt
und hier kommt jetzt die bekannte
Formulierung kann hat verschiedene
Formen des kategorische Imperativs ich
habe sie fett markiert nur noch
derjenigen Maxime also dem subjektiven
handlungsgrundsatz durch die dazu gleich
wollen kann dass er allgemeines Gesetz
werden allgemein meint natürlich für
alle vernünftigen wollen Wesen gültig
ja das ist jetzt noch sehr abstrakt hier
gibt's jetzt eine sogenannte Naturgesetz
Formel des kategorischen datens ganz
kategorische Empathie versuchte auch
verschiedene Weisen darzustellen das ist
jetzt die Formel des Naturgesetzes
irgendwie sagt er die lautet
so als ob die Maxi mit einer Handlung
Durchgang will zum allgemein Naturgesetz
werden sollte sie muss also absolute
vollständige Geld haben jetzt bringt ihr
ein paar Beispiele wie wird denn maximal
durchführen können einmal nimmt er hier
ein Menschen der Überfluss am Leben
empfindet
und jetzt
überlegt hat ob die Maxime sich in so
einem Fall das Leben zu nehmen wenn man
das Leben lebensüberdrüssig ist ob die
widerspruchsbau frei verallgemeinert
werden kann ob die also ein Naturgesetz
werden könnte nun versucht dieser Mensch
ob die Maxime seine Handlung und ein
allgemeines Naturgesetz werden könnte
natürlich kann sie das nicht aber wie
genau nicht seine Maxime aber ist ich
mache es mir auch selbst die wird im
Prinzip wenn das Leben bei seiner
längeren Fristen überdroht als
Annehmlichkeit verspricht es mir auch zu
kürzen
und jetzt erkannt das sieht man wenn man
das jetzt verallgemeine das sieht man
bald das eine Natur deren Gesetzes
nehmen durch die selbe Empfindungen
deren Bestimmung es ist zu Beförderung
des Lebens anzutragen das Leben selbst
zu zerstören er selbst widersprechen
also nicht als Natur bestehen würde okay
dann bringt noch ein weiteres Beispiel
ein anderer möchte sich Geld borgen aber
dann nicht zurückgeben also möchte
praktisch lügen
und auch hier ist erkannt dass die
Selbstliebe dabei zugrunde liegt und man
muss sich hier fragen wie es dann stehen
würde wenn meine maximum allgemeines
Gesetz würde nämlich etwas zu sprechen
deshalb nicht zu halten da kann da sehe
ich nun Vergleich dass sie niemals als
allgemeines Naturgesetz gelten und mit
sich selbst zusammenstimmen können
sondern sich selbst notwendig
widersprechen müssen warum denn die
Allgemeinheit eines Gesetzes dass jeder
nachdem er in Not zu sein glaubt
versprechen können was sie einfällt mit
dem Vorsatz ist nicht zu halten würde
das Versprechen Netzwerk die man damit
haben mag selbst unmöglich machen denn
niemand glauben würde dass ihm was
versprochen hat sondern über alles
solche Äußerung als eitles Vorgehen
lachen wird es ist ein bisschen
problematisch weil er kannte eher so ein
empirische Erklärung scheinbar
empirische Erklärung gibt es geht nicht
um soziologisch
Prognosen dass das dann jeder machen
würde also jeder würde da niemanden mehr
versprechen glauben es geht um die
Institution des versprechen überhaupt
versprechen als in der subjektive Praxis
als sprachhandlung als performative Art
der Verpflichtung der würde nicht mehr
möglich sein so muss man glaube ich eher
denken
er hat noch ein weiteres Beispiel
nämlich die verwahrlosten der eigenen
Naturgarten
dass er kann auch das geht nicht wir
müssen nach Kant durch den kategorischen
Partie unsere gesamten Naturgaben
Begabungen kultivieren denn als ein
vernünftiges Wesen will der Menschen
notwendig dass alle Vermögen in ihm
entwickelt werden weil sie ihm doch zu
allerlei möglichen Absichten die nicht
und gegeben sind es ist schon ein
bisschen anderer Fall als das Beispiel
der Selbstmord ist muss man jetzt sagen
und wir haben noch ein viertes Beispiel
ihr denkt dran
dass man an einem anderen Menschen nicht
helfen können muss so ist doch unmöglich
erkannt zu wollen dass ein solches
Prinzip als Naturgesetz alle enthalten
gelten in einem Wille der dies
Beschlüsse würde sich selbst wieder
streiten dem der Fälle sich doch manche
eignen können wo er andere Liebe und
Heilung Bedarf dieser Mensch der sich
diese Maxime gemacht hat das eben nicht
zu berücksichtigen und wurde durch ein
solches aus seinem eigenes Naturgesetz
sich selbst alle Hoffnung des Beistandes
wenn er sich wünscht haben will ein
vernünftiges Wesen ein vernünftiger will
ist er kann muss ich notwendige Weise
die Möglichkeit das Beistandes durch
andere
wünschen wollen muss es wollen und zwar
wie ein allgemeines Gesetz alles andere
wäre eines Widerspruch im vernünftigen
Wind Nachgang
ja das war jetzt ein Durchgang durch
eine sehr zentrale Passage in ganz
grundlegende die die Frage nach den
Verhältnis von Willen Vernunft und die
Frage nach den Möglichkeiten und
Begründung eines kategorischen
Imperativs betroffen hat vielen Dank für
die Aufmerksamkeit